gamm bella street market in Kinshasa
it's home to some of the city street
kids or Shigure as they are here
popularly known just want to be
gangsters others have been chased away
by their families parents are supposed
to support their children and send them
to school to have a good education the
kids often run away from neglect abuse
or persecution after being accused of
witchcraft a common belief in Congo they
have their own communities and they have
a few people who look after them the
sugar leaders for instance their former
street children themselves but as
community leaders they look after the
most vulnerable
Zoe died akiza is one of them together
with the others he checks on those who
have problems or who are sick we can't
handle all the problems but you help
them with the little means you have when
you see a street boy who is a newcomer
you help him because when you are a
newcomer you first get beaten by others
szura himself was helped by the Rieger a
local Christian NGO whose offices are
not far from the market the idea to work
with the leaders came from our founder
after he saw children who he had helped
earlier they had grown up on his streets
and couldn't be reunited with their
families so he said those who are strong
and have experience on the streets
should look after the smallest children
and protect them in an ideal case the
organization reunites the children with
their families in a year it finds
shelter for about 3,000 children but
vasila that wasn't an option he left
home when his father married another
woman today he works at the market and
tries to provide for his own family this
work I get paid by the women here in the
market they can pay you 100 Congolese
francs
this money is enough to get some rice
for the family some beans soap to wash
clothes next morning a gamble a market
the ZOA die akiza checks on a sixth
street child with a wounded knee
although the leaders wrote her a letter
to take to hospital she wants to see the
traditional healer the belief in
witchcraft is so deeply ingrained in
Connolly's culture that people trust the
healers more than the hospital the
healer was also a street boy for some
cases we go to him for treatment because
he removes the curse that they sent on
the girl without his help they would cut
off the leg any other healer would make
us pay a lot of money a hundred to two
hundred dollars for leaders like ZOA
it's a means of helping the girl for
organizations like Riza
this is still a major cause of concern
we have our infirmaries for that and we
have doctors who help us and sometimes
even work for free we have to convince
the leaders to convince the kids to go
to a hospital because it's all in the
mind of that girl but sometimes the
extreme poverty drives them to take the
cheapest and easiest way out